welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Cheryl das a senior lecturer in
international affairs and economics at
Yale University professor das is
research interest center around
household decision-making in rural
households especially in Africa in
particular she is interested in how
social and economic changes affect the
dynamics of decision-making within
households much of Professor doses
current work focuses on issues around
women's access to assets including land
today we talk with her about land
ownership and land tenure reform as it
affects women in Africa
welcome professor das thank you let's
begin with how you got involved in
researching the dynamics of households
in rural households especially in Africa
what led you to it I had spent some time
living and working in Africa I worked in
Liberia working with a women's training
program and got very interested in
trying to understand what was happening
with women and then when I started
graduate school in applied economics it
turns out that most of the models of
households treated households as though
they were individuals and so thought
about household decision-making as
though it was simply one person making a
decision but in fact we know that's not
how households make decisions most of us
in our households have many people and
although we may agree on many things we
probably don't agree on everything and
so trying to understand about the
dynamics of what happens in households
is really important because it affects
the outcomes so when women have more
power in households or less power in
households when women earn more of the
income or as we're starting to learn
when women own some of the assets it
actually affects the kinds of decisions
that households make including decisions
about if your rural households in Africa
it might affect the
decisions about what kind of crops to
grow how much of them to sell but also
decisions about sending children to
school health care and various other
kinds of things I know you've done a lot
of work as you mentioned in Liberia and
also Uganda how is land acquisition and
untenured changing in these countries so
that the everywhere in the world right
now patterns of land our land ownership
are changing in part because there's
becoming more and more pressure on land
the population is growing there's more
pressure for foreign companies are
coming in wanting to buy land in order
to grow more food to feed cities and so
the traditional patterns of land
ownership which made may not even be
ownership in the sense that we
understand it may simply be that
particular households have a right to
farm a particular plot of land but many
of them don't have any kind of documents
for ownership Wow
that's worked traditionally fairly well
there were local systems for how to
allocate how to allocate land how to
resolve conflicts and there were
traditional systems for how women had
access to land in order to be able to
farm but as both as some of the social
structures have broken down particularly
in Uganda one of the things that's
changed is an increase in hiv/aids so
you at least hear lots of stories that
when what a man dies of hiv/aids that
often his widow
will lose access to the land that she
had been farming she doesn't herself
have claim to it and other people from
the community maybe from his family who
don't have enough land will come in and
try to claim that purty piece of land so
to the extent that the system's had been
working before now that there's much
more pressure on land the systems are
starting to break down and so in
particular it's really important to
start to think about how women have
access to land and how to ensure that
particularly when their households
dissolve when their husband dies or if
he leaves how to make sure that they
still are able
to have land to support themselves and
their children
okay how do women typically own the land
or is it primarily men so it will depend
on what you mean by own so in the work
we did in Uganda over half of the
households when you actually ask them
who owns the land they will tell you
that it's the husband and wife owned it
jointly so we own the land and that
tends to be true both when we asked
husbands and when we asked wives so say
we own the land but when you actually
say well what does it mean that you own
the land whose name is on an ownership
document most of its not titled but they
may have some kind of a document that
shows who the owner is it's much much
more common for that to be in the man's
name so that it works women have access
to land they claim to be the owners but
then if anything's challenging their
rights and their husband isn't there to
support them in it they may lose lose
access to it okay and then what happens
they're kicked off the land and someone
comes I mean it seems it seems pretty
nebulous right so they may know right
they may not have access to it anymore
they may be told they can't farm that
particular piece of land somebody else
comes and farms it okay so so overall
let's talk about the gender implications
of the changes so women it sounds like
from what you're saying are becoming
worse off than they had been previously
with these changes happening or is that
incorrect they may be worse off there
could be cases where they're becoming
better off too if they have the ability
to buy land and gain a title for it then
they may be better off so there's
certainly a small group of women both in
Uganda and Liberia who own land who own
tidal land and who have really strong
claims to the land and then there's
other women but also other small holder
farmers whose access to land is being is
being threatened okay
I'm curious to know how you do your
methodology given given the topic of
households dynamic
do you actually go in and live with
anyone for a time or is it basically
surveying different families on how they
make their decisions how exactly do you
do your research so most of the work
I've been doing is survey data so we've
been collecting household survey data
interviewing multiple people within
households so where many households
simply interview the household head
we've been interviewing both the
household head whether it's a man or a
woman and other adults in the household
so in Uganda we interviewed about 350
households in three different districts
asking them questions about ownership
about documents about their rights over
the land do you have the right to sell
it can you make the decision on your own
or do you have to consult with somebody
else do you have the right to bequeath
it can you rent it out who makes the
decisions about what's get what gets
planted on the land who keeps the
revenue if you sell the the crops so a
number of different kinds of questions
to try to understand what does ownership
mean right
what is that bundle of Rights that we
see that we think of in the West as
being ownership if we owned something it
means we can sell it we can do whatever
we want with it but that's not
necessarily the case in other places
that bundle of rights may be divided up
you may have the right to farm it
without actually having the right to
sell it and does it vary within the
country for instance say within liberia
does it does it vary from a place to
place on how land ownership is is done
so both in Liberia and in Uganda there's
different forms of land ownership so
both of them have customary land tenure
systems where it's the traditional
system and that would actually what that
actually means varies across different
areas within the country and then
there's a formal legal statutory system
where some of the land has title deeds
so both of those systems occur at the
same time within one country okay are
there any track
with the changing taking place in an
acquisition and tenure I think the the
big trend is simply that there's more
and more pressure on land more people
more people wanting land and so as land
becomes more scarce than the people
without power within the household
community village country all are the
ones who are likely to lose access and
unlike this country I imagine I mean and
when I say this country I mean the
United States most of the farmland is is
controlled by big corporations there's
very few small farmers anymore in Uganda
and Liberia I would imagine and I could
be wrong in this but it seems like it's
mostly small farmers is that the case or
are there very I mean you had mentioned
there are outside companies coming in
and buying up land so how is that
changing are there up still a lot of you
know single households farmers or our
corporations taking more and more of the
land still the majority is done by small
holder farmers and still a majority of
people in both of those countries earn
their living by being small holder
farmers both countries have some kind of
large plantation agriculture and that's
growing but it's still the case that the
majority of farmers are small holder
farmers in doing your research are there
is there any one thing that particularly
surprised you I think we were surprised
in Uganda because when we went and so we
just I've been doing surveys but before
doing the surveys you have to go and do
a lot of qualitative work do a lot of
focus groups try to figure out how to
ask the right kinds of questions and
over and over
we heard statements like how can women
own property
how can property owned property and so
interests the women are considered
property people who were implying that
women were property and so how could
they be owners of property and so given
that we had heard that and that that's
part of the rhetoric about land and prop
in Uganda we were surprised that in over
50% of the households the husbands and
wives reported that they owned it
jointly which says that even though that
rhetoric is there in a lot of households
the households actually function pretty
well and the husband and wife work
together as a team to produce to produce
crops to raise a family to do all the
things that households do that to me
suggests that when we're thinking about
policies we need to think about how to
build on those households how to build
on the pieces that work so rather than
thinking about just going in and
necessarily titling land in the names of
lots of individual women how do we
ensure that in those households where
women have some claims that those claims
are strengthened okay and that if their
husbands dies the women retain the
rights to to farm that land do you think
you know moving forward 10 years or so
to your point of people saying well
women are property but yet within the
household that's not necessarily how
things work do you think moving forward
policy will be put in place where women
are thought of more as equal to men so
Uganda actually their laws are pretty
gender equal okay so they've got a
pretty good Constitution that supports
women's rights and then it's in practice
and in people's attitudes that that it
may or may not be be taking place so I
think some of those kinds of things are
changing there's certainly legislation
being discussed that would change some
of it I've been doing some other
comparative work so doing much much
larger surveys in three other countries
in India in Ecuador and in Ghana okay
where we've done similar kinds of things
asking about land and asking about all
the assets that people own and who owns
them down to the point of who owns the
cellphone and who owns the television is
that owned jointly does one of you own
it and one of the things that we find
from doing the comparative work is the
the rules about marriage and inheritance
play a big part in terms of what women
own and what women have access to so
that in places where women when you're
married you jointly owned all of the
marital property that gives women much
more ownership of assets then places
where you still own assets individually
regardless of whether you're married so
in many places including in Uganda
there's no sense of there being marital
joint property in terms of the law
whatever he has it's his and whatever
she has is hers women clearly benefit
when whatever they whatever is acquired
during marriage jointly belongs to both
of them so as long as women are still
paid less than men and take more time
out of the workforce which is true I
think everywhere then women are going to
benefit by having laws that guarantee
that half of what the marital property
is belongs to them okay very good thank
you so much for being here today I'm
sharing some of your work thank you very
much for more information about
Professor das and her research please
visit our website at Yale GDU backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale